I argue vice, I argue nice occurs once.
Day actually occurs twice now.
So you have a dual occurrence of day.
And for the word loves, you can argue.
In the strict sense, the answer is zero, and
this is what I asked you to do here.
But advanced techniques for bag-of-words tend to just look at
the stem of a word, which is love, and count it.
But the way I asked the question, it should have been zero.
Just be aware that later on, as you use actual tools, loves and
love might end up in the same bucket on the right side.
But I think you got the principle.
It's just a frequency count.
So let me ask you a few question about the technique of bag-of-words.